BRENDAN KENNY: Hi, my name
is Brendan Kenny.
I work with the Maps API team.
And I'm here to tell you as
quickly as possible how you
can make Maps in your web
browser work with the
Crossfilter library for
interesting data
visualization.
So the Crossfilter library, if
you go to their Github repo,
is a great library for helping
you explore, exactly as they
say here, multivariate
data sets.
So data sets where each of your
data points has multiple
variables associated with it.
You want to see how they
interdepend and interrelate.
So the example they have here
has to do with airline flights
and the amount of time early
that they might arrive.
And so you can see here a
classic view where you have
multiple views into
a data set.
And we can look and see
how the different
histograms here compare.
So we can see that the time of
day is relatively evenly
distributed throughout
the day, but
almost nothing at night.
And you see how the distance
and the arrival delay both
have this long tail out
towards the right.
So what's great about modern
computer technology, browser
technology is we can drop this
in and actually have these
histograms be interactive.
So I can look here.
And I can use this brush tool
to select subsets within one
of these data sets and see how
that affects the other views
within the data.
So you can see, for instance, as
I come out here to the long
tail, you get actually a large
number of flights that arrive
quite a bit earlier.
Because they're so long,
they have more
time to arrive early.
Whereas much shorter flights
tend to stick right around
zero and have that
longer tail.
And so actually, each of
these is interactive.
And so I can select subsets
within each, and see how that
affects the overall data.
And so this is great because
not only can you find new
stories in here, because
relationships within data
tends to not be even over
the full distribution.
So things that might be true
between relationships between
long flights and the arrival
delay might not be the same
relationships that, exactly as
I said, short trips have with
arrival delay.
And so if you have just summary
statistics where you
see the full thing, you're
not going to find those
relationships.
The other thing it allows you
to do is allows more lay
people to come in and discover
things about flights.
I don't know much about distance
and how that relates
to arrival delay, really.
And so just by playing around
with this, I can discover
things, and then approach things
more methodically after
I know what I'm trying
to look for.
So we want to look at how we
can apply this to Maps.
So Crossfilter is really
great for histograms
and graphs like this.
But there's no reason
why we have to limit
ourselves to that.
Crossfilter is really
just a data library.
It just spits out JavaScript
values.
And so it's up to us to
create this interface.
In fact, this interfaces
is all D3.
It's not the Crossfilter
library at all.
So I wanted to show you
how you could hook
that up quite quickly.
So we're going to start off
with an example data set.
I just created this randomly.
And I apologize for the
boring variables.
But it's just a JavaScript array
of JavaScript objects.
And in each of these objects,
we have a latitude, a
longitude, and two variables--
a val 1, a val 2, that have
different distributions
that I've generated.
And we want to see how they
relate to each other and how
they relate spatially.
And so how we introduce that
into Crossfilter is actually
quite simple.
The docs are a little daunting
at first because Crossfilter
is made to be very general,
which is great later on as you
start trying to expand
the visualization or
Crossfiltering that you do.
Being so general is
extremely helpful.
But it can make it a little
daunting to start at first.
But here's a really simple way
that you can start out.
And it's just about as
basic as you can get.
So we create our filter by just
calling the Crossfilter
function with our point data,
with that array of points.
And then, we actually create the
dimensions that we want to
explore on this data.
So by default, Crossfilter
doesn't create any dimensions.
We have to manually make those,
which is actually a
good thing, because that means
we can pass any JavaScript
objects in there.
And they can contain
functions.
They can have pointers
into the DOM.
And we don't have to worry
about Crossfilter
messing that up.
It also allows us to create
dimensions, variables that
we're interested in,
that are actually
derived from the data.
So maybe we combine two data
points into one dimension that
we want to explore.
So that's all the general
stuff you
can figure out later.
So for now, we're just going
to make it really easy.
We're going to say we're
interested in dimension of
variables that's
just the val 1.
And this is a function that's
mapped over all the points and
just returns from each
point the val 1.
And so we created an array
within Crossfilter
of all the val 1s.
And then, we make this grouping,
which is a little
bit more abstract.
But if you think of it just as
the histogram where we're
bucketing them and looking at
the frequency of each bucket
within the data set, it becomes
a little more clear.
So I know that val1 varies
over 0 to 10.
And so I just want to bucket
it by integer since it's
floating point.
I just want to floor
it and see it.
So then, I'm going to create
another dimension for val 2.
And I again return val 2.
But val 2 is a much wider range,
I think 0 to 1,000.
And so I'm going to make
larger buckets.
And so I'm going to floor
for every 25.
I'm going to bucket
it, but still keep
it at the same value.
So let's take a look at
what that looks like.
And if I refresh the page, you
can see that we have two
histograms here-- value 1, which
has this almost normal
distribution maybe.
So here's what this
looks like.
We have two histograms.
And you can see value 1 has
this normal distribution.
Value 2 is a little
bit more uniform.
And I totally ripped out the
histogram and brush code from
the Crossfilter example and just
adapted it to this data
set-- or not even adapted,
I literally used it.
And so now, we can brush and see
how the two things relate
to each other.
So that's great.
And you can see that this
is already helpful.
If these were meaningful
variables to us, then it would
be helpful.
But we want to see again
the spatial component.
So what we do next is
just add a map.
And so you saw before that that
array of points each has
a latlong value.
So I can add a map.
And then, I can just, for each
of those points, I can loop
over that and add a
marker to the map.
And for each marker,
I just set the
latlong from that point.
And now, I have a point
associated with each value.
And so this isn't a view yet.
It's really just showing
where those points are.
So I want to connect these
two views to each other.
So I need to bind first the map
to Crossfilter, and then
bind Crossfilter to the map.
So let's take a look
how to do that.
So what I want to do is bind the
current view in the map to
Crossfilter so I can filter
the data based on what's
currently in view.
So to do this, I create two
new dimensions, a latitude
dimension and a longitude
dimension.
So the simple dimensions that
we had before, or similar to
those, where they just return
those values directly.
And now, what I can do is use a
map event on bounds changed
to actually get the bounds,
the most westward and most
eastward, and most northward
to most southward.
And then, I can use those
to actually filter those
dimensions.
So I pass these things.
And I say, this is pretty much
just asking Crossfilter to
filter out all the data
points that don't
fall within that range.
So that's exactly
what we want.
We're now filtering
on the bounds.
And now, when we refresh, we
can see how that looks.
And so you can see as I move
points in and off the screen,
the histograms below change.
And this is doing exactly what
we were doing before.
We were selecting subsets of
the data by brushing within
the histogram and
seeing how that
affected the other histogram.
Now we're seeing, based on the
points that are currently on
screen, what is the distribution
of the values
that are associated
with those points?
So you can imagine
this is helpful.
As you zoom in, we can see,
just like before where we
could see the long tail distance
was associated with
certain patterns.
We could see spatially as we
zoom into certain areas of the
United States, maybe certain
values have different patterns
within that area.
You could imagine a different
tool where you are actually
dragging and selecting a
bounding box, or any sort of
thing like that.
You're selecting
census blocks.
And you could affect the
histograms below.
So now, we need it to go the
other way where selecting
what's in the histogram drives
what's on the screen.
So we do that by adding
one final dimension.
And I just call it
the ID dimension.
And there might be an easier
way to do this, but this is
the first way I thought
of doing it.
And it works OK.
So we'll use it for now.
But if anybody has better ideas,
feel free to leave them
in the comments.
There's probably a more
idiomatic way.
So in this, I just
return an ID.
So this is a little subtle.
But this is a function that's
mapped over our data with the
built-in map, array.map.
The second thing that
you get is that the
index within the array.
And so I can just return the
index of that point.
So I know which point it was
that created the current thing
that's being filtered.
And so I make a grouping
of it where it's
actually the full thing.
So I have 300 data points.
So this group is 300 buckets.
And each bucket only has one of
one thing in it, or nothing
in it if a point has
been filtered out.
And so when I created my
markers, I put them in an
array also that mirrors exactly
the point array.
And so what I can do is when
I check a bucket with a
particular ID, I can just go in
and take that ID, that same
ID, and set it to either visible
or not if that bucket
is empty or not.
So that code is that
is right down here,
where I update markers.
And so I get the grouping.
And I do grouping.all.
And this is something that--
this is where I'm not totally
sure this is the best
way of doing it.
But the nice thing about .all is
that it's not creating the
new array every time
there's a change.
It's actually using the same
array over and over again.
And so, as I said, I just
loop over those points.
And I just check--
I use the key, which is
the ID, to look up
into my markers array.
And then, I just check if
anything is in that bucket, I
set that marker to visible.
And if not, it's set
to invisible.
And so if I once more refresh
the page, I come back here.
And you can see that it's still
bound so my view affects
the Crossfilter.
And now it goes the other
way, as well.
When I filter the Crossfilter
using the other histograms, I
can see that it affects
the markers currently
drawn on the screen.
So if I only want the value 2s
that are within this range, it
will filter the histogram of
value 1s associated with the
same points.
But it also affects
the pointers that
are drawn on screen.
And so now, we have a
fully bound thing.
And you can say, things only
within this subset, looks like
this in value 2.
And it looks like
this spatially.
And so once we have this,
you can start doing
all sorts of things.
And it gets a little hairy
when you have a bunch of
markers that are even
more than this.
So this is about 300 and
actually works quite well.
There's some performance
things we can do with
de-bouncing and that
sort of thing.
But actually, the Maps API
handles it fairly well doing
exactly that.
And there's some really
interesting things we can do
with D3 and the Maps API which
both have kind of strong NVC
or data driven views.
And so there's more interesting
things we can with
binding them together.
And then, we can take a look at
things like WebGL, where we
can display many more points.
And we can express these
filter ranges in a more
interesting way, rather than
looping over each point.
And then checking, we can do
some interesting things with
actually our geometry.
But those are all talks
for another day.
So I hope this was helpful.
Check out the source code and
feel free to make Maps to your
heart's content.
We can definitely do more and
more interesting things here,
and there's no reason to limit
ourselves to just a map or
just a histogram when we
have so much better
things we could do.